welcome everybody to after dark we are
very late
but at least we're here
we're living up to the day it's almost
dark yeah
right
for the first time it might be the first
dark after
but we're here you know yeah
could have been not here i could still
be on paternity leave
right or just asleep
today's episode is sponsored by babble
and hello fresh
trust me i wish i was still asleep man
god
so long so tired
but anyway we got a great show here
today obviously as always wednesday
night that's right we're all bangers
it's friday we got some pizza on the way
yeah our troubles are
over how you feeling ella nice to have
you here
i feel good yeah good good good
percy i was at the doctor today and
everything is fine
well we weren't not that we were worried
about it no just like a checkup yeah
he's gaining weight
yeah
he says we don't have to wake him up
every three hours to feed him he can
just sleep now which is good yeah
so there you go he's a happy little
sleeper
he's a happy little uh al qaeda sleeper
cell what
i don't know it just made me think of
sleeper cell when i said he's a happy
sleeper you remember when that was the
buzzword sleeper after uh 9 11 it was
all the sleeper cells are gonna come get
you maybe you weren't here then no i
wasn't here
was that a real thing or was that just
like a scare tactic
um
i'm not allowed to i'm not at liberty to
share that group of operatives spies or
terrorists living in a secret among a
targeted community for instructions to
act
there was never a sleeper tell a sleeper
cell attack
they're like dude we need to look we
need to be able to like see everything
you're doing at all times because the
sleeper cells bro okay why is this hair
choosing to like be right here
they're sleeper cells that's right do
you want to cut it do we yes does
someone have a scissor
it could
yeah i do this is a real emergency guys
anyway
a lot to talk about
but first give me a haircut i mean
here you want me to do it okay but first
we have this too
so do you want it really like short
short like right now i don't know you
don't want that this camera's driving me
crazy you don't want bangs right no it's
like a three
no okay don't move
anybody else got this like awful
annoying hairs that just like
no
no no i don't dance
way to be insensitive
i think that you may want to
those are like super sharp
you may want to uh
[Music]
it just looks like you have like a
little shaved widow's peek down
great
you may want to take a razor to that how
much did you cut i just cut the ones
that were hanging
here oh my god you're crazy
i thought one hair like one single no
there was like three that were launching
i feel like i feel like a thing here
take a photo like a chunk here take a
photo oh my god it's in here
oh my god that's why i didn't do it
yeah you're crazy take a photo you
take a photo
what do you mean i'm crazy
why do i still trust you with scissors
after all these years yeah you take a
picture
okay you guys tell me if i'm crazy i do
yes yes you are crazy
it looks like you haven't shaved for a
couple i thought one hair you were gonna
cut
here i'm gonna post this on my instagram
stories so you guys can tell me
oh my god i did exactly what you asked
dude here look
the fact that i can feel it is like
something's wrong actually dan maybe you
can pull it up it's on my instagram
stories
so that people can see
well listen don't you feel better now
i do there you go until i look in the
middle except my thank yous
just keep me away from mirrors
there
that's a good like 10 hairs or something
15. yeah
that's probably more than that maybe
i could have trusted you no i'm not no
you're smart absolutely this wasn't you
know it's not gonna happen my hands are
too shaky i'm no there's no way i'm even
getting close with scissors to your face
i'm sorry no he's right you don't want
that heat from ela because she could be
mad at me she can't be mad at you you
know
never forget man
the first time you asked me to cut your
hair you cried and cried
and you hid yourself you wouldn't even
look at me
i said this is what you wanted to do
yeah all right
probably told this story before but
either wanted me to take all of her hair
she had really long hair tie it into a
bow tie
or well into a ball pigtail what the
[ __ ] you call it
ponytail
and just do it in one cut says okay what
the [ __ ]
[Music]
somehow it ended up so shy
her hair was like this long well ethan
cut it before
the ponytail not after
where i was i thought it was pretty
obvious it would be after
so it was like it was like right against
my head you cut it
so like the hair here was like up to
here
i'm not
and that's how i started wearing beanies
it looked horrible dude
but i still i still thought you looked
good
thanks yeah of course i [ __ ] up
anyway guys before we move on look at
this shirt
this is the uh
what do you call this the melting logo
the melting logo shirt
new teddyfresh.com it's really cool
it's actually sewn i don't know if you
could tell
but there's a whole new drop here
oh thank you dan
yeah just you can scroll
quilted
looney tunes deal with it the
pants
i don't know if you want to supplement
my commentary here you look keep going
then pants
uh
shirt
another the same
shirt the hoodie it's a fascinating
insight you're providing
uh this is a good one i would rather go
to hell
than go to work anyone else here feel
that way
not me you were feeling that way this
morning afternoon i just wanted a little
more sleep that's all
i would rather go to hell but i have
felt that way before
love it i heart tf
you know what it is
oh these sweaters are super nice man
these came out great
beautiful and of course
the melted logo tea
the gangnam style
the gingham style
it's just blood oh just plaid what's the
difference in plaid and gingham yeah
gengar is the one that's like tiny and
like um
just like black and white or red and
white
like tiny square opam
kingdom style
that's right
anyway whatever just go to
teddyfresh.com you know what it is
yeah actually a funny thing happened at
teddy freeze a little drama this morning
so
i'm gonna make an announcement next
thursday right hilo oh you're announcing
it yeah okay
we have a big collaboration with el and
john whoa
i feel like i just said his name funny
we have a big collaboration coming out
with elton john who were who we love
funny enough elton john was the first
and probably one of only two out
physical albums i've ever bought in my
life the first album i ever bought
was elton john's greatest hits
fantastic living legend how about that
you only you've only bought two album
like physical albums because i was right
at the cut off man i bought i bought
like uh elton john yeah we were kids we
were at the cut-off are you talking
about lps like vinyl no like oh
a dv a cd bro i'm i'm with you dan i had
a lot more cds than that i feel like
what can i tell you i didn't have any i
used to burn them myself yeah
you know yeah i mean i was on the i was
downloading [ __ ] bro i was on limewire
and whatever napster
you wouldn't steal a car would you
[Laughter]
i mean
if it were i could probably would if it
was as easy as downloading music no i
don't know i know music yeah
but i wanted to give you a serious
answer to a serious question
i only inherited cds from my brothers
and like
all almost all of it was just empty
boxes oh yeah i'll see the inside
what a great gift yeah
man it's so awesome thinking back on the
see the cd it's like exactly half of
them are empty they're in the wrong case
they're all scratched up they don't play
i mean what kind of world were we living
in physical media
unbelievable
well anyway
uh what was the other one i bought elton
jones greatest hits and
god maybe that was the only one life
after death
yeah maybe why do you know that
why'd you say that don't worry about it
no i feel like you said in an old video
that you bought a big ecd one
it might have actually been that
[ __ ] weirdo
why do you know that
life after simping my dog
but anyway
anything else you want to tell me about
myself baby
you're not good at cutting hair
yep
that's true
so anyway
huge elton john
fan and elton john collaboration is
dropping next week which were super came
out amazing
by the way some licensors are
less good to work with elton was like
the best we've ever worked with yeah so
gracious
good feedback super nice
enthusiastic pretty cool
well i i don't
think i can say it but he personally
loved the designs
i was gonna ask if you actually wow
that's really cool yeah
very cool we sent him a bunch of stuff
right yeah i think we did good
so sick anyway i love elton
and um well anyway we sent out i'm not
gonna we sent out some seating pr stuff
to a influencer i'm not gonna say who
they are and don't go try to look them
up because i don't it's not worth giving
them [ __ ] and harassing them that's not
the point it's just
a funny story but
this
this person
uh
it was sent to them early
and
they immediately put it on d-pop
before even before the collaboration
dropped so there's people like yo what's
this teddy fresh elton john stuff on
d-pop
it's crazy
this is a crazy thing to do isn't it
yeah it is very wild
but on the plus side it did sell
people wanted it would have felt worse
if it didn't so
but we're like we're like what the hell
dude so weird crazy
that's actually happened to us before
too we sent it to a famous model
that one's a little more understandable
i mean it's not understandable but it
was a little different where
we don't think it even reached the model
it was just probably like her
publicist or whatever yeah
they put it up they just straight up
they take [ __ ] and then they just it
goes straight to depop i'm like oh my
god but especially something unreleased
like that i was just kind of floored
it's just so
tasteless
so classless it's weird it's like if you
don't want it i think just give it to a
friend or family right like don't
don't sell something you were gifted
no well no
but it's not even released yet that too
but
even beside the point
i don't know because i get i guess in a
way it's like
let's say
you're kaya gerber
and i'm not saying that's the person who
i'm not the i'm not saying that's the
person we sent it to who did that
but i am using her name
uh the first time not the ellen john one
but let's say you're kaya gerber super
famous supermodel and you get uh you get
a ton she probably gets so much crap
like where do you even put it all
so much gifting and pr and stuff
and then say your best friend works for
you if you if you don't want it don't
accept it i agree i have to accept it i
agree i'm just trying to paint a picture
where it makes sense yeah and let's say
her best friend works with her doing
whatever dumb [ __ ] she's her assistant
and she's like yo can i sell this [ __ ]
on depop i'll make like ten thousand
dollars a month selling all this stuff
that you don't even
that's just piling up but
obviously there needs to be some
consideration
right
to where that goes what are your guys
thoughts
trash order that is so [ __ ] up yes i
don't want to say too much because i
don't know who this person is or
anything but that's so [ __ ] up by the
way it wasn't kaia gerber she was the
person that happened the first time i'm
not the ellen john one i'm not gonna out
her yeah it's [ __ ] up that one's on
for that one's worse i mean you have
this exclusive uh
you know um product
and
they're just they're just gonna sell it
like
it's just [ __ ]
thanks bro i mean isn't it like uh
just basic like somebody gives you a
gift you don't go and sell the gift
immediately yeah it's common decency a
straight to d-pop never worn
a re-gift is better than doing tags on
it and [ __ ] people are saying it was a b
oh it's a b no i would never sell that
[ __ ]
the av doesn't get pr we make him pay
full price for that [ __ ]
anyway interesting story
um oh there's a new bts is that what the
shout out to the members is yep new bts
is up you wanna what's going on with the
bts uh so this week was a little
different we need to do a normal bts
because
we were in the office as much because
the schedule is a little switched up
right now so uh we did a little q a on
instagram we asked what questions people
have and we answered for members oh
that's fun
yeah so thank you to all of our members
you know
um there's a weekly bts for you guys up
there it is
uh we have a ringo star update
to the goat you see this yet i haven't
oh good
another great night with jimmy kendall
peace in love
[Laughter]
this is a serious message to jimmy kenno
i want to tell you please
what is this
i want to tell you please jimmy kennel
i'm warning you no more m's
kennel thank you thank you
i think that's an autocorrect thing
thank you yeah it could be it could be
kimmel versus
yeah
jimbo kimball yeah i like jim bull
kimball
so thank you thank you you know i've
been watching um
euphoria we did like marathoned it and i
think i'm depressed
well we just yeah we just watched like
probably the most depressing part of the
show last night i think it was all
depressing i guess
but the whole show from beginning to end
was sad i mean i couldn't do it
it made me feel old made me feel sad i
love it though it doesn't make me feel
old and it makes me think like was i
such a nerd in high school like because
i didn't know any of this was going on i
think it's different where you grew up a
little bit i mean i don't think that you
guys are nuns in israel but
like that [ __ ] happened at my school we
were debating how realistic you know
euphoria is because
of all the the hijinks going on and
insanity and i feel like all those
archetypes with all those people are
people that i actually knew in high
school
i agree with crazy
you agree with that yeah well dan agrees
too
i mean well i mean i knew about i
haven't actually watched the show so i
can't really speak to it but i mean that
i know what it's about and the kind of
stuff that goes on and yeah that was
definitely my high school
the most i knew about is like cigarettes
in high school yeah
well weren't there bad kids that were
doing all kinds of craziness there yeah
but i think i just wasn't hanging out
with them probably
like i said i think i was on the nerdier
side
dork
well my parents wouldn't let me do
anything too yeah i wonder if your your
overly strict dad was was i had friends
that would go out and
be with guys and stuff like that but
then my dad wouldn't let me do any of
that
that doesn't stop these kids
you're just a good kid
um
my that was
very strict not like strict
i don't know you're more scared of you i
was scared of him yeah than
what you wanted to go out yeah yeah
yeah true
but uh sam and ian loved the show too
did you know
that the show euphoria is an adaptation
of an israeli show
yeah which one it's an adaptation of the
israeli television miniseries of the
same name
seriously oh i didn't know that
i just saw somebody in chat say that
yeah
so i guess it is going on in israel too
there you go yeah dude israelis are
crazy dude
no way well i'm gonna watch that now
yeah there you go
it says this is apparently a minion
group of 17 year olds who spend time
carelessly having sex taking drugs
seemingly no parental authority
whoa
adults appear only rarely and were
always filmed at an angle that did not
show their faces oh that sounds a little
more artsy because there's there are
parents in this show right
but there's definitely a lack of
parental guidance
there you go elo you were a nerd
[Applause]
confirmed
it was a really good show i mean it's a
great show it's a beautiful show but god
it just makes me sad when i watch it bro
makes me sad and worried for theodore
i know we're like so scared now
i went up and tucked him in because he
woke up at 4 am and i'm like
i have to protect you
i love you oh i've got to tuck your feet
[Laughter]
he just said it again a few days ago i
come home from work he runs right up to
me goes what i'll talk yeah
and again it's been like a month or
something since he said it i was like no
no no no before you came he came behind
me like he put his arms on me and he and
he whispered it in my ear
it was like what the [ __ ] oh my god did
you laugh i laughed i couldn't and then
it was like
uh he was saying like i want to say to
dad when he gets here
and then you did
i didn't laugh though i was good yeah i
was like no no no no no we don't say
that we don't say that
[Laughter]
yeah
yeah yeah
what else we got here
uh a coach
and something about metaverse i love the
metaverse it's so [ __ ] dumb
uh mark zuckerberg is a wait until you
see he's an [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] freak
show hold on [ __ ] the metaverse and
everything involved with the coach now
you're gonna regret what you're saying
okay you're gonna be impressed so the
title of this is nba commissioner adam
silver
unveils coach of the future
coach nat
in the metaverse
communicate by zoom
stop what stop this [ __ ]
why the [ __ ] is president obama involved
in this dump
garbage
you have stained your legacy sir by
being in this
on the stage and demonstrate to everyone
what you're able to do with these
that's
clinics
oh god holy cow i mean i holy cow i
thought about him during the pandemic
but
i'd never stood next to him my role is
to help coach no that's shaq's voice no
that's coach nat
why is jack he's shack
[Laughter]
this is supposed to look impressive what
does it look like oh you're not wait
what what are you talking about okay
wait let me remind you i'm not gonna
pause i'm just gonna listen to shaq talk
to me like i don't know pick someone
whose voice i don't immediately
recognize if you're trying to create
some new avatar
i mean i've heard a lot about him during
the pandemic but
i've never stood next to him talked
about that was to help coach train
develop the next generation of nba
talent i know all the best moves
and i'm untethered by one single
dimension
i can even make a free throw
before you leave anything else
[Music]
what are they demonstrating
these people doing this they they're so
confused about what the metaverse is
even them they don't know how to convey
it in a way that makes any sense yeah
this is just a 3d model that looks trash
what is it
what the [ __ ] is it why was obama on the
call
why is this happening
i don't know it really is stolen why
couldn't they make his eyes look like
eyes
right well because they are confused
they don't know what's happening
delete me from this conversation i wish
you would delete yourself from these
goddamn ad shock take a vacation man
done everything
the mansion insurance commercial he's in
computer commercials he's in meta
commercials he's in car commercials yeah
he's even like sponsored by this watch
company he's he's everywhere man
he must be a bargain dude you must be
like a really good rate oh yeah should
we look into it let's hire can we get
him to spokesman teddy freddy
yeah i mean i wonder like we could
probably get him for a couple hundred
thousand
he's got to be cheap that's why they're
all doing him yeah
or is just that relatable that people
will just see him and buy it he is
relatable but he's he must also be cheap
maybe he's not cheap though
there's no [ __ ] way dude
there's no way
there's no way he must be cheap as hell
they get like a list from their agent
they're like you can get him for this
him for this and they're like shaq
cheapest one
what are we going to say b
now i'm just going to say
samuel jackson who's also in everything
last night i mean i got a notification
from our alexa saying would you like
samuel jackson
to run the alexa and i was curious and
now we say hey samuel and he'll be like
what do you need [ __ ] really
yeah oh god he's not as much stuff as
shaq is he he's in like every movie
somehow yeah he's maybe not he's as
diverse as shaq yeah
movies is fine i don't want that he's
not in the middle of it it's pretty
[ __ ] cool yeah well that sounds fun
dude
um
president barack obama discusses
basketball's promising future in africa
i'm going to start with president obama
and
sir i'd just like to say i think
everyone here would would love to hear
from you obama you're sitting next to
coach nat
sir this is beneath you this is beneath
the office that you represent in terms
of what you see the opportunities in
africa
thanks adam
wait is he in the metaverse still
what the [ __ ] hey whoa is that coach nat
yeah she's crazy he's out on the court
yep he's out there
crazy bro that's revolutionary whatever
that is
nobody knows what it is
my chicago bulls who are having an
outstanding season
but i am also thrilled to be part of nba
africa
i really believe that what the nba is
doing in africa will make what are they
doing
beyond just what does this have to do
with zach
because it doesn't necessarily you know
i mean metaverse is uh a broader thing
than just uh facebook stuff they they
they're just i mean they rebranded
themselves as meta in an attempt to make
that association in everyone's head that
like facebook equals metaverse but other
companies are doing metaverse things as
well
no but the metaverse is a facebook
place i don't know it's a virtual place
that facebook owns
that
yeah
yeah
it's the name of their digital space
it's about learning how to work hard and
how to compete shut up
are you doing this obama
okay anyway by the way talking about
dumb crypto [ __ ] because i'm just so
annoyed with this stuff lately i've been
looking for this clip and i finally
found it last night
you know three in the morning
garyvee everyone needs to stop saying
he's smart i'm sick of people telling me
garyvee is smart and interesting he's
such a dumb obnoxious [ __ ]
i hate him
i really hate him too listen to this
listen to this genius idea to make money
with nfts i'll give you a weird one if
you own a home that is wildly unique and
is a 25 million dollar home on a beach
or something wild you nft that home
right now put into the smart contract
that you get one percent of every
transaction of this home in perpetuity
and the first person that's gonna buy it
from you is gonna be fine with that they
don't give them i'll give you a weird
one this is so stupid
what the [ __ ] is he saying he's saying
that so you're telling me that somebody
that owns a 25 million dollar home is
going to care about
making one percent side money on an nfd
first of all yeah his his advice to make
money is be rich already
yeah and by the way it's still bad
advice second of all how do you enough
to your house
just a picture of it is he not talking
about the smart contract for the house
like it doesn't matter what are you
talking about
like if selling the house comes along
with some sort of smart contract where
every time it's sold for all time he'll
receive a residual oh that is parasitic
[ __ ] trash and it would never be
enforceable like that's that's
even worse that's even more [ __ ] up
than i thought when he said nft scammed
a house why would anybody go for that
one percent in perpetuity yeah that's
like i'd be like what is wrong with you
you're disgusting
i hate it
you know i heard a really good there's
this one video the problem with nfts and
he made a really good point he goes
people think like nfts and crypto is all
about like
freedom and decentralization and all
it's really doing is monetizing
everything
these guys like garyvee they dream about
putting everything in the in on the
blockchain like a house
you know how we how do we make money
from everything how do we monetize every
[ __ ] thing in my life garyvee is
literally just scribbling dog [ __ ] on a
napkin and selling it to you [ __ ]
suckers
for hundreds of thousands of dollars
shame on you all
that video was great by the way yeah you
guys checked it out yeah we watched it
oh yeah i watched the whole thing
it's a good one check out daniel shout
out the full name of the video if
somebody wants i did it's the problem
with nft oh that's it yeah
uh folding ideas is the channel and uh
dan olson is the host of it been a fan
of his for a long time it was a really
good video i just don't get the gary vee
[ __ ] i don't get it what i really liked
the point that he made also was like
it's a problem if the only value
of something is just how much it's going
to be worth in the future yeah a
speculative asset that
that means there's a problem right there
it's only worth money if more people
keep putting money into it it has no
inherent value yeah period
like you're only buying something
because you're wondering how much you
could sell it for later
that
and it's only worth money if some other
idiot comes in and buys it at a higher
price
yeah i just bought 39 million
of safe moon
safe moon baby real quick
oh hey
somebody wants to say what's up gabe
what's going on baby
pissing my ass
he's uh connecting his audience pissing
my ass baby
hey gabe kissing my ass
pissing my ass still not connected there
you go hey there it is
hi ethan how you doing how you been man
long time no see where are you at now
it's time to see i'm at the store i'm
getting a suit a suit you're getting a
suit where are you ross
i'm at um nordstrom rack getting a suit
getting ready
for a wedding on the weekend
oh yeah
i love that
what do you got in your hand there
i've got i got a receipt i'm i'm getting
this thing tailored and i'm buying the
suit
what a guy you know looking sharp huh
hell yeah yeah hell yeah
baby how you been anything
i i made a new um i made a new um day
instead of friday i call it first
saturday and second saturday
okay what does that mean
that means like friday friday is just
another saturday so i kind of nicknamed
it
so friday's first saturday
first saturday baby happy first saturday
yeah
how's the how's the piss in my ass thing
going it's pretty working and i got a
new um i got a new um
i got a new phrase too big dick energy
oh big dick energy
that's good yeah big thick energy
yeah
maybe you could throw maybe you could
throw in like something just a little
more obscene like horse [ __ ] energy
yeah
i'll try that one but i can't really say
it i'm in i'm in front of people
yeah no if that's fair enough you don't
want to say horoscope energy in public
yeah
yeah
but um well that's that's exciting i
hope you have a great time happy first
saturday to you
first saturday tomorrow second saturday
yeah what do you call sun or well what
do you call sunday
this sunday just sunday
yeah and you know what monday is
president's day so
so that'll be a four-day weekend no no
work and no school no for real no work
no school baby
[Music]
are you buying right now you paying yeah
i'll hang out with you
let's hang out all right make sure you
show your credit card on screen yeah no
damn no don't do that gabe don't do that
yeah you just do just do the transaction
we'll we'll mind you just do that and
we'll mind our own business here and you
you handle that but keep the phone on
yeah okay cool
yeah so gabe's buying his suit
go ahead gabe don't worry about us
how you doing what you've been doing the
past three weeks
no you could just buy the suit we'll
just carry on the show and we'll check
in with you when you're done
all right
all right cool man
we're here yeah all right
yeah so gabe's buying the suit
everything's going over there pretty
good uh but you know
i like the idea of second saturday don't
you guys so oh yeah
not to disrespect first saturday the
second saturday are you still listening
well no disrespect to gabe but i feel
like it's a little unfair to the og
saturday to call it second saturday
maybe friday should be like saturday eve
like it's like the day before like it's
like a prequel to this did you hear that
gabe
yeah
or just friday you know like you know
like friday and saturday the same day
so no i don't know so dan says that
maybe it's disrespectful
to the first sat sat traditional
saturday to call it second saturday
right because it was it was saturday
first
yeah oh gee saturday
right so maybe friday could be um cam
cam suggested saturday junior saturday
junior
all right yeah we could just leave it
friday just you know just leave it
friday yeah yeah
let's just leave it friday okay
everyone's out doing their errands and
playing their um party or you know
in the evening whatever they need to do
that's why it's called that way same
routine like saturday friday and
saturday
that works
that makes sense to me
how's it going why is it taking so long
there
are you checking this
candy
oh sure no problem
[Laughter]
so gabe is buying a blazer
which is fantastic he called us in line
about to reach the cashier and i just
want to
follow this through all the way
and we're invested now and i want to
make sure he gets the blazer
there it is yeah
touchdown we got the blazer in the car
looking good let's go the purchase is
complete
no no still being processed i'm removing
the security attack
yeah there's a lot going on there
okay been busy
yeah
oh
[Laughter]
i don't think
yeah so it really takes a long time yeah
you can really feel it
last time we went to ross or something
it did take a while
remember
yeah
no nothing
you asked me to open the card i can't do
that
yeah
this is good stuff guys
friday evening
baby
this is top saturday eve content i have
nothing to i have nothing to add oh okay
we're not going to see your pin right
gabe he switched away nope it's secret
it's very good
is it one one one
the car go through
we're waiting and we're gonna see
okay fantastic okay well i'm glad that
you got that all squared away i want to
make sure
well thanks for calling gabe
sure nice to check in with you it's been
a while baby
[ __ ]
who baby my you know
big energy
hell yeah horse [ __ ] energy
[Laughter]
all right all right take care we'll talk
to you next week okay bud have a good
time at the wedding yeah all right
happy long weekend [ __ ] baby baby
all right take care
exciting
all righty
all right all right all right all righty
heading out now bye-bye see ya buddy hi
all right all right
energy bye-bye
yeah big deep energy
all right see you next time take care
all right okay bye-bye
all right all right see you man you can
yeah thanks bro
that was you can blame dan for
prolonging that time
[Applause]
that was exciting yeah that's great
it's compelling
it is it is break time
you know after that high level of
excitement i think you can cool off
oh god uh video of poor skier slamming
his [ __ ] and balls directly into a
this is from the olympics
oh wait let me go back
is that really his sound this is from uh
the olympics in like 2006 i
believe does he is he left up
i think it's a mic from far away
honestly it could even be fake but
either one of his [ __ ] hairs
but you know i'm kind of surprised by
that because this guy must have done
this a million times like one is he not
wearing a cup if this is a risk and two
he must like
i just i'm surprised that he was able to
injure himself like that
it's like he chopped his dick off
and you could hear it
and if you're a man you could feel it
wow watch this again
[Laughter]
is a french alpine skier who competed in
the 2006 winter olympics well no the
footage is real yeah i'm wondering if
this the commentary probably
i'm saying though
based on this article
ladies and gentlemen the nutcracker
oh the gate to the groin for yannick
bear tron and you could hear it
and if you're a man you could feel it
wow watch this again this guy are you
serious right now dude
oh the frenchman why are you wearing a
cup oh miss ya
wow the
but do you know what i'm saying like how
can you be so vulnerable to that injury
it seems obvious
i don't know if you're a professional
he must have slammed his [ __ ] into a
pole like a million times the pressure
got to him
that's great
that's good um
there's one more thing at the top of the
show here then we'll do ads
uh i s a lot of people in the suburb
have been posting this you see this you
apparently there's an attorney
in illinois who's looking to sue triller
no way i have no vested interest in this
obviously but i'm just i just find it
interesting it says apparently
um
laboten lobotomy lobotomy laboton
such arrow what the hell name is that
dude such arrow such a row
sushiro
anyway
it says users had their data collected
without giving the consent required in
illinois
under dipa
sign up today to join the class action
lawsuit against triller
man that's crazy did triller steal your
face that guy says yes when does that
mean
it's a force of nature
i actually have no idea apparently
illinois has really crazy restrictive
facial
recognition laws oh
specifically that state but if you live
in illinois this is a thing that's
happening so
i mean i don't know which one sorry i'm
i don't know this law firm i'm not
recommending you reach out or anything
i'm not affiliated at all
just informing the people
that this is something happening in
illinois there is a clashed action
lawsuit against trailer
yeah uh illinois law prohibits private
sector companies and institutions from
collecting biometric data from
unsuspecting citizens in the in the
state or online no matter where the
business is that sounds like a good law
for the whole country
yeah
let's not do the biometrics let's just
skip that yeah
uh here's a quote from the website
someone said in the comments we believe
that triller has ignored the protection
implemented by illinois lawmakers
through its collection of users
biometric data without first notifying
its users and obtaining written consent
which we intend to prove at trial
okay
get after yourself
ryan kavanagh
doing something shady
there's no shot
no shot this man is up and up
have you read his wikipedia page it's
spectac it's it's it's a
spotless right
all right let's thank our sponsors real
fast
babble
thank you to babble
whether it's saving more and spending
less
getting organized or losing weight
there's a lot of worthwhile goals to set
yourself this year at the top of my list
is learning a new language with babel
the language learning app that sold more
than 10 million subscribers
ian is learning learning french very
studiously tell me the most complex
sentence you can in french right now in
i mean there's an easy one you can use
if you ever see a skier
get in accidents we misused monsieur
you learned that on babel yes i did
actually wow came in handy your french
is so impressive bro thank you
no but seriously it's good right the
lessons
yeah
the repetition and it mixes like images
with the words and it really like drills
it into your head are you really
learning french
i'm trying i'm trying when i can't yeah
we
yeah
yeah he's been stuck on we for about a
month now
not only is learning a new language fun
and engaging new hobby but you can use
it to uh while you check off traveling
more from your list as well the whole
babel process is addictively fun fast
and easy and babel teaches bite-sized
language lessons for real world use
[Music]
they have 50 minute lessons that make it
easy
make it the perfect way to learn a new
language on the go
other language learning apps use ai for
their lesson plans but babel lessons
were created by over 100 language
experts their teaching methods have been
statistically proven to be effective and
with babel you can choose from 14
different languages including
spanish french italian german
come on eh
you know i realized that um
theodore and bruce
are five percent italian
right
five percent because ela's
varying on who you test
10 to
15 italian wow five percent is
everything yeah so theodore's five
percent italian he's gotta come on huh
the man loves pasta you got this he's
got that swagger don't be catching you
with any of that italia phobia out there
huh
hell no
he's a person of color
anyway where the [ __ ] was i
there are uh
plus
babel's speech recognition technology
helps you to improve your pronunciations
and accent there are so many ways to
learn with babble in addition to lessons
you can access podcast games videos
stories and even live classes plus it
comes with a 20 day money back guarantee
no brainer nothing to lose start your
new language learning journey today with
babel right now when you purchase a
three-month babble subscription you'll
get an additional three months for free
that's six months for the price of three
just go to babel.com and use the promo
code after dark that's b a b b e l
dot com code after dark
babble language for
life
[Music]
and thank you so much finally to hello
fresh we love so well
hello fresh it's all happening
with hellofresh you get farm fresh
pre-portioned ingredients and seasonal
recipes delivered right to your doorstep
skip trips to the grocery store and
count on hellofresh to make home cooking
easy fun and affordable and that's why
it's america's number one meal kit
let's see that burrito
abe made this burrito with hello fresh
did you ever tell us what's in it
was there meat in it
there was there was it was a chicken uh
quesadilla that looks like a burrito
wait that was a chicken quesadilla yeah
see i didn't know we didn't know that
the burrito
yes what quesadilla bro what why does it
look like that
uh i need lena here today i'm i'm not
sure
i forget the whole story wow this is new
information lina explain this it's a
whole new twist
lena come on maybe's burrito is actually
a quesadilla
so it was supposed to be a quesadilla
but then he folded it like a burrito
interesting differently that's all
he folded it
why do you do that
do you remember why i do remember why
i don't know if i want to say it right
now
okay because i didn't i wasn't familiar
at the time bro i wasn't familiar at the
time with you know what it was is the
first time i took home a package from
the office and it was vegetarian and i
didn't know if the whole program was
vegetarian only and so i put meat in it
and i didn't know if i was able to show
the meat so i oh
that's why this is the photo oh but why
would they oh cause you added
ingredients
i didn't know because dan's a vegetarian
he ordered it that way yo i didn't know
you had the option so i have an another
twist okay this is very interesting the
the member on discord uh pterodactyl
that always sends me a bunch of their
beautiful photos of their hellofresh
just messaged me and said this is what
abe's burrito was supposed to look like
oh my god
look at that
that is that is glorious that is
beautiful i and you i don't see a
difference
[Laughter]
right now that looks good
the plate's a little different
i don't know if i use the sauce
oh my god
that's awesome wow
okay
we learn more about that burrito every
day just when you think you've learned
everything
it's quite a difference maybe
more next week some deep lore for this
burrito yeah
hellofresh is 72 cheaper than a
restaurant meal of the same quality and
you can save on average 65 per month
when you order hellofresh instead of
grocery store shopping that's money back
in your pocket people
uh hellofresh offers 50 menu and market
items to choose from every week
including veggie fit and wholesome
family friendly and gourmet options
providing
plenty of variety this is how it works
you know they send you a box with with
perfectly portioned amounts a card that
explains about the food and how to cook
it it's a great learning experience
learning how to cook the food and
prepare it and it always comes out like
fresh and delicious and it's always
balanced and beautiful
and we have a special offer
go to hellofresh.com after dark 16 and
use code after dark 16 for up to 16 free
meals and three free gifts
once again
hellofresh.com after dark 16 and use
code after dark 16 for up to 16 free
meals and three free gifts thank you
thank you hello fresh america's number
one meal kit
all right
wow deep lore we're learning more about
this burrito every day it's actually
now we know not even a burrito
yes
so you wrapped it in shame you wrapped
it to hide the ingredients because you
added meat
yes
that's so funny
why'd you wait so long to tell us now i
feel like we've been giving you [ __ ] for
so long
i think i may mention it to the crew i
just i don't know i understand on there
i always mean to tell you and i forget
to tell you after the show yeah
also when did your hair turn gray again
right
yesterday i can tell yeah it's kind of
purple i don't know i just felt too 90s
the way it was
can i call ab out for something right
now sure please okay so like he's been
telling me or he told me last episode
he's like you got to turn my mic up you
got to turn my mic up he's not even
talking into the mic right now
i just my mic sounded really low av do
you complain to zach about your mic
being too low that was the first time
you're not it
talk into it
tilt it talk into it
hi
wait
do people think that abs mic has
traditionally been too low
i don't think so i know it was the first
time i said anything last time i was
just driving listen to the podcast and i
felt like my mic was really low the way
he has his mic tilted it's not the
proper direction for that type of
microphone that is true it needs to go
right up yeah point it at your mouth so
that's zac feedback did you tell him
that off the air zach well i'm just
observing that now he was waiting for
this gotcha moment well i cranked up
your gain on your mic but like i'm like
i don't want i don't want ab being too
loud now it's not that a b well no now
i'm going to turn them down you know to
adjust but i i just want to point that
out
he points out [ __ ] on me and i'm trying
to help him i'm trying to so zach feels
called out
zach felt called out when you told him
hey the levels are off when i texted him
privately
chill dude back up from your mic a
little bit
when i texted him privately
and my mic seems a little
say that again
dan's [ __ ] with the fader
all right
um
let's get to okay i've i've been on a
i've been up first of all there's pizza
here if anyone wants go for it i want
bring me everything
really
eat come on the pizza is here we still
got a lot of show to do left
uh i've been trying to get the tinder
swindler banned on cameo yeah
and cameos and culture they're not
running
cancer culture run them up yeah
and you're next whoever's listening well
there's something going on outside it's
like hella loud the uh
sirens yeah
do you have can you someone like me is
cameo page i want to see if it's up
still
oh it is they well because they're
they're standing by their decision to uh
yeah so they say they replied
to the tweet
yeah not to the tweet but they made a
statement show me it's the first link
it says uh sources tell
simon has allegedly signed it's not the
first link it is i'm looking at it right
here link to reddit post right here well
it needs a little information damn it's
just the first time the first link
someone emailed cameo regarding this and
this was their response
yeah so it says
thanks for reaching out we appreciate
your feedback while making sure it's
heard by the appropriate team cameo aims
to be a ubiquitous marketplace that
means we allow fans to choose who they
want to connect with and we allow talent
from all background and belief systems
to participate as long as they do not
violate our community guidelines for
your awareness i wanted to share cameo's
company's statement part of what makes
cameo special is that we allow criminals
we like criminals
and uh murderers
uh
r wordis essayists and all varieties of
personalities on our platform
and as a ubiquitous marketplace our
customers are in control of the
connections they choose to make we don't
do not endorse the beliefs of uh anyone
who uses the platform simon levi joined
cameo this week and he will be held to
the same standard as the rest of the
cameo community yeah
uh you know
i uh i emailed the people i know too and
they told me the same thing really lego
where's the line is r kelly allowed to
make a cameo
is bill cosby allowed to make a cameo
is uh jeffrey dahmer i mean if he was
alive allowed to make a cameo
like this guy is a [ __ ] danger to the
society there's wait a minute
is
is oj on
cameo or was he at one point don't tell
me
jay simpson i don't think so i think i
would have seen that
i think oj is afraid of making clear
income because like nicole
nicole brown's family just gets every
money he makes to think
except his pension
right
hey
yours truly if i did it i'd tell you
here
top comment is actually they say to be
honest who played devil's advocate he
committed a crime went to jail served
time even though it should have been
more time and left jail he definitely
already paid for his crimes [ __ ]
he's an idiot yes is he a douchebag
yes but so far as he has to commit a
crime that we know of therefore cammy
doesn't reason to ban him
uh following the same logic every x-con
should be banned from every single
social media platform that is ev
that sets a dangerous precedent
it's not really a social media platform
because it's a it's a content
like uh
it's a service i mean it's not really
social media i wouldn't necessarily i
wouldn't be like yo twitter banned him
for being on twitter
but there's something about him being on
cameo and having fans pay him for videos
that is insidious and disgusting and
gross but also that's how like
i don't know he's going to find a way to
use that
oh for sure connect with people and then
he's a predator
no but but to be honest i'm not saying
you can't be rehabilitated i'm not
saying ban every ex-con i don't know
every x-con story i don't know
everyone's uh i do know that this guy
escaped prosecution for his worst crimes
in europe served five years in jail and
he's back on his [ __ ]
he's back on his [ __ ] louis vuitton
private plane
this guy is at the bottom of the barrel
dog [ __ ]
he he is the worst person one of the
worst people you could ever imagine
so
while i'm not in favor of banning every
ex-con but like this one i do know so
like you only spend five months in jail
yeah yeah i just for unrelated crime
right
well you said five years
five years he spent five months in jail
in israel unrelated crime he has not
i repeat not
served his time he has not
been uh rehab rehabilitated or
reinstated into society he served in
israel for a crime he committed when he
was like 18 he has not
been sentenced in europe
and i don't believe he has shown any
remorse or any like growth i think he's
just gonna continue to do the same thing
based on what he's showing i believe he
is uh
i saw to an article that he's um
either threatening to or is suing
netflix
wait no oh yeah of course good luck yeah
good luck with that
um and then you know
i'm sorry but i strongly disagree with
this there's got to be a line you're
telling me you wouldn't be mad if r
kelly had a cameo
i was like girl
meet me outside the prison
what if he would sing passports
what if he signed passports for us
i'd buy one but i'm just saying
i'd pay premium for that
what about um if he were to uh
get um a deal to produce a reality show
or kelly no this guy
would that be too far of course right
well so that's happening too
well okay so yeah i'm getting more into
this [ __ ] scumbag but here's the
problem he's on cameo making cameos he's
already being idolized by like you know
the fresh and fit morons they follow him
they do yeah i think they're trying to
get him on their show
sick
and they're going to be like yeah this
guy they i heard him talking about him
they go this guy's exposing women for
who they really are
picking coconuts oh my god coconuts and
barbados exposing them by scamming them
because because they're greedy because
yeah they're all they're all gold
diggers because he was pretending to be
a billionaire wow right
yeah
yeah but didn't he
approach
them
you know what i mean they met on dating
apps right and they thought he was a
billionaire because he immediately said
that and then offered to fly them
somewhere on a private jet right more
than that they were they would be dating
for
sometimes up to a year and he would put
them in the nice hotels and the jet and
everything and he had the yachts and the
whole thing and the designer clothes he
would they would be looking for
apartments together
like insane levels of
crazy of of emotional manipulation all
while having sex with them by the way i
hate that he's israeli too on top of
everything
such a disgrace
yeah but as soon as i saw that i knew
he'd be a red pill hero
gross
well anyway yeah so now not only is
cameo been like it's all good
but don't you guys agree like there's
got to be a limit
on who they're let on their [ __ ]
platform
okay osama bin laden be making cameos
that's what they're saying
right
i know he's dead the thing that maybe
people don't realize about cameo but
we're aware because all these guys
signed up with them or whatever is not
anybody can sign up first of all and you
have to go through like a whole
onboarding process with them and
everything and in most cases like i know
this was the case with you ethan and
maybe with these guys i don't remember
how exactly went down but cameos the
people they reach out
and like trying to get people on so i'm
not saying we don't know that's how it
happened
they did the editorial process right
simon levi and said this guy's a good
fit which is why i'm saying it's like
it's not it's not really comparable to
call it a social media platform in a
weird way it's almost like a production
like similar to like a production it's
an exclusive club they have to let you
in right yeah
contract with them and you're creating
content and they're taking a cut so
they're [ __ ] lying when they go we're
a ubiquitous marketplace no you're not
right you're an exclusive club
you [ __ ] you sick [ __ ] you guys all have
to close your cameo oh no
it's just that like
hey take that off
get that out of there sorry go ahead
what's [ __ ] up is that he ruined those
girls lives forever yeah they have that
that will take them like forever to pay
back forever and he only did five months
and now he's able to do this all over
again that's just [ __ ] up also i'm not
going to say he like
r-worded them but to have sex with
someone like under that false pretense
and you're shopping together you're
looking for an apartment together i mean
everything was like
they gave exactly they give them him
their whole life their their
their body everything
and then to find out that he was
scamming you not just that that's a
stretch to call it our word yeah i mean
it it stuck it is yeah i mean it it i'm
sure to them right i'm i don't i don't
want to check for that word
but i would call that i would call that
our word mental abuse yeah it's
definitely so like this is this guy is
dog this guy did this to so many women
it's [ __ ] disgusting dude yeah it's
pretty crazy let's do a poll should he
be because that was the top comment
apparently people think that this
[ __ ] guy should be on cameo let's do
a pull
should should simon be banned from cameo
yes or no and if you guys vote no
you need to shut down your cameo and
protest
all of you
you can bring it back up when they
when they uh
really none of you guys put it [ __ ]
stand by your principal i don't stand by
my pencils
you guys will get it back when they
uh
oh my god okay somebody's super i'll
never forget zach just moved out in him
he's a young lad he's doing well on
there he's on the trending page what's
the uh what's the vote
it's 88 yes thank you thank you
bad poll every [ __ ] time some but
some
it's not a bad poll i know
it's just every time we make a video so
you you all this is worded poorly i
don't understand what's happening we
can't figure it out so you
you think we should
make a promise if you guys shut off your
cameo in protest
when they ban him
we will do a whole our cameos our back
party and promote you guys to make up
for all the lost revenue
that's solid you'll probably end up
making more money that way that's fair
enough but you risk i don't think
they're going to ban them that's what
i'm saying you run the risk of never
getting your cameo
i can
they're doing great let them you have to
decide right now
i'm just kidding i'm just kidding i uh
it's here this person said he's a
predator i think we should compare his
out of prison requirements to how sexual
predators are restricted yes
[ __ ] you
to the person who wrote that i'm sorry i
know you say you're playing devil's
advocate but it's not a good comparison
this guy's a sexual predator put him on
a [ __ ] list he doesn't get to vote he
he's a danger to him to the everyone
around him
get him off cameo
put him in a [ __ ] hole dude send him
to a pit with snakes for all i care
so
to to play devil's advocate oh yeah no
no but um because i haven't i didn't
watch the documentary
i just learned about it the other day
when ethan talked on the show i hadn't
even heard about this whole story um
is the documentary like iron like he
definitely did this like hundred percent
yeah it's not like there's no ambiguity
you see the girls and you see i feel
like there's everything has like proof
you know to back it up
and everything okay
yeah there's no ambiguity okay well the
money side there's all transactions that
you can see so so no it hasn't been
prosecuted likely just because in europe
he got extradited to israel
he got extradited or he fled to israel
because he's an israeli citizen right so
he just like went back home i think they
just said get the [ __ ] out of europe
because he got arrested for
faking having a fake passport or
something i say and then i think they
just said get the [ __ ] out of europe
they deported him yeah departed him back
to israel so
he's probably not going to get
prosecuted because he's not a citizen in
europe
at all and and the only crime israel
could charge him for with some like
identity fraud he did back before he
left
yeah no it's not it's it's it's dude
there's videos of him he's sending
videos of himself being i love you honey
there's voice mentioned i need the money
you have to send the money you have to
get take out of finance your house you
have to get your grandma's credit card
you have to do all this the people are
after me just you got to watch the
documentary shame on you cameo
disgusting
i don't even think this but just to play
devil's eye for a second
throwback well anyway in other news
simon is uh signed with a talent manager
and hopes to star in his own dating show
who wants to fund my luxurious lifestyle
it's called
a dating show yes you heard that right
folks
the tinder swindler simon levi i can
make it in hollywood trust me
wait wasn't there a reality show that
kind of was that concept it was like a
really [ __ ] up
show like dating show from the early
2000's yes yes yes joe it was called joe
millionaire oh we're watching the new
one now yeah we're watching right now
one's a millionaire and one's not
it was no it was like it was basically
the bachelor it was the bachelor but
the all the girls on the show were told
that he was like a playboy
multi-millionaire and he wasn't he was
just like a plumber and they revealed
that at the end which like
is super [ __ ] up in the same way that
this is except it was this full-on
[ __ ] reality show
yeah so i'm watching the new one it's
good it's not as bad though because
basically they they'd be upfront with
the girls this time they there's one guy
who's a normal dude right and there's
one guy who's worth like 10 million
bucks and they tell the girls one of
them is rich one of them is poor but you
don't know who it is it's actually a
nice show i like it
okay
it doesn't seem cruel at all that's
cruel though and what's [ __ ] up is
that the girls get the blame they go you
jerk you yeah you are all he's like no
they [ __ ] lie to you bro
i'm sorry but
if you're like ready to have a family
nobody's you know
the job makes a big difference
right
everyone knows that
i can't lie about that
anyway i can't wait to see his his uh
dating show called how many girls can i
r word in one summer somebody super chat
said the winner of his dating show is
the woman with the best credit
yeah
that's awesome
simon's new hollywood manager gina
rodriguez
with
guitoni incorporated
and we're told they're already discussed
a bunch of plans to parlay newfound
netflix fame to profit and entertainment
career there's no [ __ ] way anyway
dude i'd be shocked if anyone picks this
[ __ ] up please don't tell me this
gitoni entertainment is another israeli
too well
some people speculate it's probably even
him
because that's an israeli name
gitoni incorporated um
or at least itself the manager's name is
her last name is rodriguez
anyway they're getting bad reviews
already on
but people say that they call well here
let me read the article
um
simon's hollywood we're told their
discussion
we're told simon's idea for a potential
dating show includes women competing for
his love
you serious
so crazy as you know simon's the subject
of new netflix documentary in which
women and law enforcement claim he blah
blah blah
yeah
some people are saying he's uh
pretending to be his own agent which
makes sense to me and he would do that
i would date like the absolute youngest
oh my god
now is there a second part of that zach
or is that the whole thing that's it
oh i remember that because he says i
would date the youngest looking guy i
could find right right yeah that was on
logan yeah he actually said that
yeah absolutely i know
i would date another club yeah i could
find
there's like what there's this one
people still [ __ ] with james charles the
uh the snapchat swindler
i got over excited this sister swindler
sorry
mr swindler let's play that again mr
swindled i'm not physically attracted to
older guys
right
i think he's trying to tell us something
i'm not attracted to the older guys i
date the youngest possible looking
person where's the pizza man what the
[ __ ]
come on now people are or some people
are asking
if we watch the kanye documentary no you
didn't i watched like
some of it is it good
it is good it's pretty good i have a new
found respect for
mike mike my mic is on but talk talking
well you know you know whose opinion i
really want
oh they're official representatives sir
ian and i know you watched the
documentary don't
pretend
like you didn't put cue that [ __ ] up day
one
i haven't watched it
are you serious i'm serious i haven't
watched it wow you really are out you're
out
i knew all this stuff anyway
i thought it was um what was a really
interesting scene is um so it chosen
from the very beginning
this guy who was a stand-up comedian i
guess decided to just like give up on
that and follow him and record him
yeah he moved to new york with him
so he's recorded him from the really
early on and uh the one thing that i
thought was super interesting to see is
they he really wanted to sign with
rockefeller
and he knew where their office is i
guess and they just went there with his
song and he just like
walked into people's rooms and started
playing the song and singing it to them
and they were just back on the phone
like not paying attention to hell and
then you walk into another room calling
the song and start singing it to them
kanye knew those guys because he was
producing for jay-z
so he was already a known producer right
yeah he was people would buy beats from
him okay right yeah but even so when the
scene he was talking about like he would
go in the office and the girls would
kind of be like weirded out and he was
like listen this is me and they'd be
like trying to continue their work
you're like listen listen like it didn't
sound good or was it kind of just it did
sound good yeah he sold it yeah
it's very inspiring baby baby
bring to daddy yes yes
it's crazy but there is something i
don't know somewhat commendable about
like his crazy ambition in the beginning
like when you know before he came up
like
he didn't sell for anything his dreams
of uh wanting to be with rockefeller
there were other big labels that wanted
him he's like he didn't want to settle
and uh yeah
i don't know where things went south
around what time but where did things go
south with rockefeller
with what
with him and things went out with him
personally and jay-z no
they two degree yeah he was tweeting out
about uh
jay-z and beyonce not inviting him and
kim over and
stuff like that
like publicly kill bro damn
that was a while later that was like 26.
yeah that was like a long time a lot
later
well anyway i guess i i've heard good
things
i'm just like not
but then i'm not looking to like kanye i
know it's kind of annoying that it came
out now when it's being so
not okay because that will make you like
him
but it's just part one so i don't know
i don't know about part two and three
because they may cover like the darker
twists and turns
sam have you watched it
no i am
she has not i was just trying to see if
ian was being truthful
she said no he told me off camera he
didn't watch it yet do you plan to watch
it again
maybe i don't know i'm listening i'm
watching a great show on hbo i'm
chilling
i'll get to it maybe what are you
watching right now
it's called station 11.
it's a mini series it's like a sci-fi
thing it's pretty good
okay okay but i hope you guys are all
enjoying the kanye i'm sure you guys
have a lot of thoughts
i haven't seen it
i i happen to very much enjoy
the documentary i find it very inspiring
his drive and
um
yeah i think it's cool
all right we'll shout out
what do you think about la rams
quarterback matthew steph for letting a
woman just [ __ ] die
have you seen this hilo
i briefly saw it i didn't know what to
do so people are really mad at him
and let's just watch this and and okay
let's just watch this
wait what's with the music
oh it's like the event
is that added music or is that from the
event
it's from the internet okay
yo that must have been a really hard
fall because he was like
look he goes like oh [ __ ] to himself
but is she can she walk or
she can't is she like paralyzed
that's a really high code
she had
she fractured her spine really yeah so
there's if you look below there's some
wow some other stuff
the way he pieces out is pretty wild
it's pretty weird
that is pretty weird
i saw someone say maybe he's drunk which
would maybe help
justify it a little bit
um
but people are really mad at him
now this is his wife
she seems to at least care yeah
kemp said almost you're to his spine
it's pretty college to like just peace
the [ __ ] out you can't do the eating and
talking i'm not going to allow it
so you either eat quickly
and then talk
or no eating the pizza is very good it's
so [ __ ] good dude yeah holy [ __ ] holy
[ __ ] it's so [ __ ] good this is a
love's first pizza in america oh really
yeah surprisingly yeah
and like the crust is so like nice and
caramelized which one you're eating the
barbecue chicken i should just grab the
pepperoni yeah but i have some barbecue
too
graham gravitate
so are we mad at him are we
what do we think
let me see it one more time yeah one
more time
he's like oh
dude how do you how do you not try to
help
what do you think happened there his
first intuition is to just say [ __ ] this
how weird
but i mean at the end of the day
what can he do
it's just like not
it's not human no it's not you just see
it and then be like okay
i'm walking away
yeah he could have called for help
because he's the star of the show people
are going to listen to him if he starts
going hey yeah yeah someone needs help
here yeah
so is he canceled
i don't know that it's like something to
cancel him for
i think he's gonna take a while to live
this one down
he knew it was bad you could tell on his
face
oh my god why is this stage so tall
people falling off stages is one of my
favorite genres but
there you go
um
saw the incident happen live
she fractured her spine that's crazy she
posted on instagram and pictures showing
that she's in a brace and here you want
to see a picture of her
unfortunately fractured my spine today
feeling okay
staying the night in the trauma center
huh
uh there's been a gofundme made for okay
50 000 bucks wow really people are nice
i wonder if he donated
that'd be good that'd be that that that
set him straight right
travis travis you could you could
uh who the [ __ ] is pat mcafee
incorporated
he's number one
isn't that uh
is not the
what's his name
the guy who died he died
the mcafee guy that's a football player
no
oh no he's so yeah unrelated
he's just some uh
sports commentator guy he happens to
look kind of similar like that guy
are you thinking of john madden
no
not at all so there you go
what do we think
i guess he could have done more what if
he was drunk like so drunk he's like i
can't deal with this right now
i don't really see how being drunk is
related right
i mean we're not seeing off stage what
if like there were a bunch of people
that immediately you do see off stage
here let's say to help because i think
that because if she was just laying
there
like he's the only person that saw that
happen and he did that that would
obviously be a dick you can see
you can see down here
this is his wife here
she's out here just all [ __ ] up
pancakes
so there are people here a lot right but
like his wife does the human
right reaction at least look to see if
yeah
it's pretty callous
shout out
i guess it's that the result of uh
repeatedly getting smashed in the head
his whole life there's that you're good
bro where is that
moving on to um
what are we moving on to
well we've got some wendy williams
conspiracies
really
two days ago wendy williams posted a
video for walking on a beach giving a
life update
people are saying that it might be fake
but this is the verified
yeah fake out
it says uh some fans are speculating the
video is old due to a few clues she says
i'm here in florida and i come here
often you know i've got a real
family here mother father sister brother
however wendy's mother died in 2020.
she mentions multiple times in the video
she's 56 however wendy turned 57 in july
that's weird
so the wendy williams shows potentially
posting old footage
to cover up for her being
i guess
unwell free windy
pretty windy yeah wendy might be
entering a conservatorship too which is
crazy should she suffer
actually ironically wendy should have
been in a conservatorship even before
her health declined i mean that one was
a menace to
it's just after society o'clock [ __ ]
hurricane going on what's happening i'm
doing okay you know
beautiful sky
it's nice being here
beautiful weather what is
you know i've got real family
you know
mother father sister brother family
family family family
this is weird
it's very peaceful
being here you know
very peaceful it's very peaceful
[Laughter]
i have real family yeah okay this is
really going full circle with the windy
williams
very ideal out here in florida
ignoring the
category five hurricane i can't do this
i cannot i can't not eat the pizza i'm
gonna walk out let's take the let's take
the pizza i can't do this you're gonna
eat after the show take the pizza away
are you being so good no you weren't
people complaining i'm complaining
[Music]
look at this
it seems windy because it is
is it always like this or is it usually
warmer
uh
it's usually no it's not usually warmer
it's still winter it usually gets up to
they say 80 degrees but i haven't
holding the door
i i don't want the wind from my face
and then
in a couple of hours
i go to my gym are you working out after
this yeah
oh wow
you know what i think this is a weekend
at bernie's situation i think her body
is reanimated
he's being held up by her nephew or
something yeah
you
no i like to go early because after i
work out
is she holding the [ __ ] is this video is
she holding anything in her hand because
i thought she was on the phone
why would they post this
it's very strange
the real oh this is her personal page
that was like the wendy williams show
it's a weird first post
this is her first and only post yeah
she's two posts now but
oh no way
[Laughter]
okay
well
listen
uh i guess they're she's holding like a
wig or the hair oh her wig is about to
fall
down here beautiful florida
hang on my wig is about to blow off my
head
okay whatever wendy
i wish you well and i
miss you on the wendy williams show
cause whoever's gonna come after you
ain't gonna provide the memes like you
did
it's unclear who made the new wendy
williams uh instagram account her
publicist had no comment on thursday
citing a gag order
in a recent court case concerning a
possible guardianship for williams jeez
it was recent
it was recently announced that sherry
shepard will take over as permanent
guest host
who's that she used to be on the view
she's not wendy williams man why are you
how are you gonna put it different the
show is called the wendy williams show
yeah well the audience has that covered
all right
yeah
okay you know this next segment's for
you
this is something we talked about doing
earlier in the week
and eli said no you have to wait for me
to do this
kanye has popularized what ela has
considered the worst fashion trend
in decades maybe of all time the boots
elo
hate it
here's kanye with his mask
i was like what dude this guy is out of
his mind man
but really what's what
ignited this conversation
yeah is the baby
okay so here we go the best comment i
saw is the babies dressed like
donald duck bro
okay
so connie craziest fit ever did this is
his fault
he did this
he did that
this is just not it
is it just the boots or is it the whole
look
the rest of it could work depending on
how you work it but the boot is just
unacceptable
and it's like a rain boot it's is that
like a luxury boot or like just a
straight up it's it's
rubber but i'm sure it's some designer
expensive one
the ones that kanye wears i think
they're balenciaga right
yeah here is
well let's take a look because there's
some really good ones so kanye obviously
is the trendsetter you can at least give
him credit for being original okay
no he's definitely
he
is a trendsetter there's no doubt about
it unfortunately
i don't haven't seen anyone wearing a
white dude mask yet in public but i'm
sure that'll catch on you ain't got the
answer sway
so here is him
wait is this photoshopped
no no because kanye's short and keith's
like towering over
khalid
probably the boots
yeah those boots are great because they
are tall
the boots have like a platform yeah okay
no wonder he likes the boots that's like
five inches cal is five seven
oh [ __ ] so he's pretty short
so anyway
so here he's hanging out with with
khaled you got it you guys gonna love
this
now
[ __ ] khaled takes a photo in the same
spot in the same
identical outfit
he bit his whole freaking outfit from
the boots up
in the same spot look at this
boots pants jacket glasses
boots
pants same exact he absorbs he absorbed
his power
imagine booed him
that's is that's kind of embarrassing
isn't it oh yeah
it's like kanye just like stayed the
night or something and forgot his
clothes oh
they're about the same height
yo khalid
leave your clothes
another one
[Laughter]
dude that's so corny
it's so corny
and then you got [ __ ] donald duck
looking after the baby here
oh speaking of it he looks like
someone's grandma
a new collab just dropped
down
he looks like someone's aunt dude
he's dressed like someone's aunt
he's about to [ __ ] wash the dishes or
something
uh
a b a b posted this
that's a fake a b
fake baby antonio brown so what do you
think about the boots here
it's a disgrace
i don't know i just feel like everybody
wearing it looks like a [ __ ] boy
what's the most [ __ ] boy garment we've
seen in the past while there used to be
a really [ __ ] i mean the pro the pro
bath shop hat is like
the [ __ ] boy item of the
current moment it's like you know
they're like there's like the
trendsetter and then there's like the
fashion victims right that's what these
guys look like that's interesting
that's interesting
here is that's yi
with his uh
balenciagas
wait this is a b no this is this is
antonio brown maybe they hang out
together yeah you thought this was kanye
right
oh dude because he's wearing a mask
exactly
wait no way dude you can't go out there
with the mask bro the whole denim look
which kanye's been doing
yo
that's whack bro
that he's just straight biting his style
man maybe
do you think kanye's pissed or he likes
it
yeah
i'm i'm sure he's thrilled
right i mean they were sitting together
at the super bowl so i don't yeah
everyone tell me yeah everyone he rolls
with ends up dressing like this
that's so funny man i gotta roll up
someday with just some ski mask and some
boots on and just be like yo
call me y call me
he
instead of eath eath all right ek
call me
e
call me anne
what the [ __ ] is this
well this is unique because he's wearing
them but he has them tucked in
whoa
that's a fashion crime right here though
that's awful
you can't tuck in the boots why are you
wearing boots
just wear shoes bro these are like crocs
now
is that a fashion crime or like croc
boots
yeah what's going on outside there's
like
there's so many emergency vehicles i
don't know if you guys can hear it we're
going to walk out of here and it's just
going to be like this is the world
zombie is there something in the news
someone check local news
sounds like gta oh yeah seriously forgot
about this little patch i have here now
can we see it
yeah you just take a razor that'll be no
problem just get some shaving cream and
shave that down
maybe pluck them
i'm not touching it
yo there's a full on calamity
fire you ever heard that many sirens in
your life love
nah
i've never heard more than two gta 5
star yeah in gta i have heard it before
that's true
um
so anyway you know i've been feeling a
little bit insecure because obviously i
work in fashion with my wife
and i consider myself somewhat of a
fashion icon a fashionista
fashionista
and i don't want to be shown up by kanye
so i've designed my own boot
have you yeah
this is a teddy fresh prototype can't be
any worse i've like i said i consider
myself a trendsetter so let me just show
you guys my new boot
yo
that's [ __ ] sick
that's a boot
that's a [ __ ] boot
it's a full body boot wow wow it's all
boot
it's a 100 boot
dos boot it's all boot no body
then you know yeah give us a twirl no
don't no no
it's just a vibe yeah it's salad's gonna
be
kyle's gonna be in one of these here
pretty soon i'm not gonna lie it seems a
little unwieldy and i have my own av who
can rip my style too oh yeah
he'll be on that
no it's just it takes a little
to be honest it's just a prototype
i really wanted to get hand holes
right
oh through the sides yeah so and then so
i could also wear boots that kind of
oh oh so let's show my feet
so theoretically i'd like to be wearing
boots right yeah
in fact we have boobs
bootception are you looking fresh as
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] it's a good look this is
an upgrade wait let me put on my drills
no is this a cop or a drop
that's a cop for sure
[Music]
style dude these are the balenciagas
the new valencia that's just dropped i
got these for 25 bucks
on the amazon boy they smell bad eh
they smell like they were just
like came out of the acid
oh god
fresh off the the press there sorry
alfredo he's so cool so here's my video
cool check it out
right so fashionable now you may think
that this looks funny with shorts but i
feel like this looks better than tucking
it into your pants
let's see stand up
here they can see on the screen yeah
yeah
give us a little
give us a little bit of a new boot
goofing
excuse me
oh my god
that's more of a vibe than what kanye
was wearing is he survived yeah it's a
little bit that's not bad yeah i like
when the show gets just right to the
boot yeah
but here's when it really goes to the
next level
right bootception
yeah i know this this this is great
this is great i'm completely think i'm
convinced how does it look i love it
that's what i'm saying they're not
dedicated they could take it further
right
[Applause]
this is a boot couture
it's really easy to
there's wheels there you know there are
wheels well it's pretty heavy so it
needs some assistance right
but what do you i mean looks pretty good
yeah i know it's the prototype but um
i'm seeing some logistical issues here
yeah it's okay it's falling
[Music]
oh my god i do smell those boots all the
way from there
that's crazy
and that's a gag
oh god i wonder if all these guys are
walking around smiling like that
i have a feeling that balenciagas don't
stink yeah and they probably don't it's
just the 25 amazon special
i think they stink
yeah i smelled the rare
there you go valencia is probably just
getting off amazon slapping their logo
on there it could be
by the way there's other kanye stuff
like when he bought a bag for
julius star
he bought birkin bags julia fox
julia who's julius starr is that a
person
there's probably somebody named julia
somewhere uh
julia ilvest
julia gullia
um
so
he bought her and her friends all birkin
bags which is like 70 000
what's bags on
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
wait we were just listening music the
whole time whatever uh
there you go
now that's great oh this was we're not
done with the boots
this [ __ ] is [ __ ] unforgivable
look at this
these are yeezys right yeah
this is the worst thing i've ever seen
yeah i hate it
and the way that the foot
goes in there it looks like a high heel
it is sort of a high heel
[Laughter]
you're wearing high heels right now
those are going for 825 on stockx right
now damn
fat gel rocking um
that joe is wild dude yo this look is
[ __ ]
the boots are just actually he would be
looking good if he was just wearing like
shoes
sneakers i follow fat joe on instagram
and he's like the most biggest boomer
ever it's so fun that's why i follow him
oh
let's pull it up
i just love his fashion styles too is
all of it this wild yes he's very out
there surprisingly he's adventurous eh
yeah
super entertaining the sirens are still
happening
yeah did you guys find what's going on i
saw there was a fire earlier
like several hours ago in downtown
massive fire um big commercial building
oh i don't know if that's what it is
though i mean i'm still looking right
now huh
yeah i mean a massive fire could do it
it's looking pretty tanner
let me take a listen
like does he still go by fijo it's the
name of his account yeah not so fat as
it used to be actually
he used to be massive he actually seems
to have lost a lot of weight
okay we posted this
yesterday's boot is not today's boot
but that's what i mean you might as well
just go
you might as well just go that far at
this point
that doesn't look like you can even walk
in the damn things
look at the size of that boot bro
it goes all the way up to his knee
practically and it looks like it's three
sizes too big for him
here
that's how it looks to me
there you have it
boot chic ela
ela does not like the boot
cheek
okay i'm sending you something by the
way balenciaga already has me on their
website sick
that looks awesome bro
i wonder what that's going to retail at
it's a lot of material so it's probably
expensive
um also
just to show fat joe a little love
with the smallest resolution picture
ever
damn he lost a lot of weight boy he used
to look like kane uh kingpin straight up
he got that uncle fester
oh dude that suit is wild man
[ __ ]
shake that on
oh yeah
that's big pun on the red big bun make
fat joe look like a skinny legend
damn get those two together they have a
good old time eating some lunch
i'd like to join them for a meal and
just see what goes down big pond is dead
right yeah
yeah
that's why i sent the lore's photo
sorry about that it's okay
shout out to his family
but anyway julia fox and kanye broke up
after after she said she was his muse
like on goddamn
uncut jam
can you can you link with that julia fox
is so embarrassing
she went on to call me daddy and she
goes i'm kanye's muse like i was this
guy's music and i'm cutting jack
sam made a pretty fire tick
doing that right
i did see that and i liked it
i got jams
here it is
do you have your past box
did you get your shots what's up friends
it's madison here and we need to talk
about julia fox yes kanye west's now
former girlfriend of two months julia
fox and that's because she's now going
viral get to the [ __ ] point
she pronounced her film
uncut with alex cooper on the call her
daddy podcast now just a few days prior
i'm about to [ __ ] i'm about to lose
my mind it's on the spotify tick tock
no no
no we're committed now that was maybe
she did confirm she was josh sandy's
news for uncut gems i have a green
screen version i'm going wild about
instead no no i'm committed julia
pronounces uncut gems so did you watch
this before you sent it to me
clearly
i couldn't fast forward the short all
right listen for yourself i mean i was
josh safty's news when he wrote on kajal
right see what i mean okay
say what i mean
actually thanks for the commentary uh
what's trending
let me open this one because this
actually didn't show enough i mean i was
josh safty's news when he wrote on kajal
right
what the hell i got
uncut
he's news when he wrote on kajal right
[Laughter]
apparently she was a dominatrix or
something and that she used to like
dominate the guy who wrote uncut gems
really so apparently she was has now
saved herself
um
yeah a little
bro imagine the hoods for to say that
that's probably why i dumped her he's
like no no no
no one that's ever been with that one is
it this one with the newest wait a
minute i haven't seen this
going on with this little dance movement
i mean this is a [ __ ] i'm trying to
get ian to move do something for the
show for years
and he's putting all the good content on
sam's tick tock i mean this is this is
outrageous
ian what the [ __ ] bro
[Laughter]
uh
there was very very long negotiations
oh
[Applause]
what was the negotiation like sam to get
ian involved in that
sam
things got a little heated because i did
not want to do it
oh really
fairly enthusiastic here yeah how'd that
go down how'd you get him how'd you get
him into that sam we got into like a
legit argument about this
you would not do it and i was like it's
fun
and he ate it up
look at him he's all committed and [ __ ]
you got the moves look at that little
twerk
yeah so are you happy you did it in the
ndn
it it cooled the room so yes
wow you just did it to cool the room
sometimes you know you got to do what
you got yeah we all have to make
sacrifices
that's what i'm saying you seem a little
more committed than just calling once i
go
i'm
you had funny and come on but it also it
got some views so that's got to feel
nice
yeah it makes me really pumped oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
just watch that ass shake
over and over
uh this is not why we're here though
yeah well that's why it is
muse
yeah a little maybe what is a muse i
mean i was josh safty's muse when he
wrote on kajal right
so let me watch um that's so good i may
watch the original remember you were
like this is not the first time
what what is a muse i mean i was josh
zafdi's muse when he wrote uncut do you
know what i mean like things like she
asked what is the music i think people
make it seem a little bit she asks
what's a muse and she goes well i was
this guy's mad then i got sad
man you think she likes
like she had to like think about she was
going to say it like that
or do you think it just naturally came
out like that i think that's so small
that's just how she does it man
which is how it's done you know what i
mean it's not like van gogh like type of
like yes he he just yeah he wants to
dress me right now
oh my god you know uh
okay wait i think he dumped her
immediately after that
picking coconuts from barbados
yep same type of energy
so
you know we've been
not really talking a lot about kanye i
mean i don't know what sir to say
he's a psychotic he's a freak he's
trying to get pete davidson killed i
think like actually yep
i have a theory though that i haven't oh
you lose my oh my
that happened to me
do you guys think that pete davidson
[ __ ] his way a little close to the sun
with the kim kardashian thing
like i feel like obviously kanye is
unhinged
and obviously misogynistic how he's like
torturing his wife and she of course she
can have sex with whoever she wants
that's what he's about to say it's not
she's a freak
she could do whatever she wants
but pete davidson is a serial cloud
[ __ ]
he's a clown [ __ ]
okay
nobody can deny it right do you united
pete davidson's a club [ __ ]
ela
uh meaning that he gets into
relationships purely for the clout is
that what you're saying
his dating history is a little
suspicious like why
is why are all the famous and beautiful
ladies want to be with him he's a cloud
[ __ ]
because he's good he's a juicer he's a
charming guy who apparently has a big
dick okay hold on hold on
hey dan a little sus i mean that's what
he definitely everybody always does he's
got a hog dude
all right let's first let's establish
something before i uh
before i roll out my theory let's take a
poll is pete
hate
davidson
fan
out of ten a cloud [ __ ]
and again you gotta consider his dating
history batpole
because the minute he started dating
ariana grande
he became super famous
he was basically a small known cast
member of snl right he started dating
ariana
became super famous and he kept
on the club [ __ ] little known fact
before he was dating ariana he was
engaged to her and she broke up with him
it doesn't matter it does matter that
yeah because who they were dating for
like three months who proposes after
three months
he [ __ ] his way to the tippy top man
that's what i'm saying and you know he
was who he was dating before he was
famous he was also a clout [ __ ] you
know he was dating before ariana larry
david's daughter
he's he's [ __ ] the pyramid man larry
david's daughter that's what i mean
nobody she's not really like a celebrity
though whoa she's kind of pretty close
to a big one yeah there's a always
recruiting comedians to be on his shows
he he's [ __ ] he's know what he's doing
he knows where you're going so did you
do a poll
next last time yes i did and it's uh
about 66 okay so we've established that
he's a club
though i'm being told i'm getting uh
scattered reports that it's a bad thing
so what what is like the end-all be-all
like tippy topic well that's what i'm
saying is that he [ __ ] his way too
close to the sun
i think queen of england would be like
yeah for sure
but but he he he he's
dating kim kardashian it's too much it's
too much the heat that that brings is
just too much
he she just broke up with connie kanye
is a pig
and i'm not making a judgment on kim she
can [ __ ] whoever she wants the problem
is that like maybe it's just a bad time
to have this argument because it seems
like
you're kind of i don't missing the point
no i know i know what you're trying to
say but i feel like the timing is maybe
not ready for this kind of conversation
this is just about pete
he [ __ ] his way to the top
what's who's next oprah michelle obama
you know what i mean yeah
i don't think hillary can't really
kim right
that's what i'm saying he and now he's
he's brought on the wrath of ye and all
of his insane stances
because now it's his name
no one calls him ye it's it's yay if
you're gonna do like the short version
i'm not a fan i'm not a mega fan i'm not
a mega fan at all
it's why
i got a like kanye west yeah
okay
is there anything else you wanted to add
to this no it's just that happened
earlier and and i tried to kind of
course correct and you didn't understand
what i was getting you want to say
something conversation is a mess
i'm just saying pete [ __ ] his way too
close to the sun
he's out of his league
i think it's a bad take because right
now he's embroiled in a controversy with
because it's like almost in the next
breath you're gonna say that
it's his fault yeah exactly it's not you
you think that well you are coming close
to victim blaming here he's being
harassed bro i've been i've been a
billionaire psychopath right now i'm
being i've been talking about it all
week listen kanye's i'm just like that's
why i was saying i know the point you're
trying to make i know it's unreal it's
not his fault i just think but he's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] and he [ __ ] this i'm
close to the song i agree with that
ethan i don't
think he's anything he
he knew
i'm just saying bro you [ __ ] too close
to the sun
you know what they say when you put your
when you [ __ ] the sun your dick gets
burned
let's do a poll now and people say did
pete davidson [ __ ] his way too close to
the sun yes or no
i am not victim blaming i am simply
observing davidson [ __ ] his way he got
too successful
there's no one left for cloud [ __ ] he
club [ __ ] his way
to the top supreme court justice
sotomayor that's the next one
kim [ __ ] kardashian
all right your poll has been
been issued come on people
you know i'm right
60 yes it's the same same percentage you
know i'm round because it's basically
the same question people
no it's not it's not the same question
here someone's saying it kind of sounds
like you're saying you deserved it
maybe yeah i can understand it kind of
but i'm not saying that just but but
that's what it sounds like okay well who
cares so don't say it i mean what the
[ __ ] i don't care
i don't care i don't care if you say
something that sounds like something i'm
fine i don't care okay
what the [ __ ] are you saying i just
don't care what the [ __ ] is kim
kardashian and now his life is a is a
you know i mean
i mean ultimately i think his life is
going to be fine i mean unless
kanye actually does
a hitman yeah super chat here very but
you know
bad thing
okay fine bad take i'm allowed to have a
bad take
i'm just trying to be entertaining i had
a thought i was like he took it too far
he can't [ __ ] too far
we can acknowledge both you [ __ ] too far
about that and kanye's a psycho
psychopathic billionaire who's
trying to get him killed
both things are true
wait what was that last one
i love that
i just think we're concentrating on on
the wrong crime the real crime here is
of course
yeah this tattoo dude that was all the
things the problem
okay he can [ __ ] whoever he wants i i do
not give a [ __ ] but this
do you want to cry okay you want to know
the proof that this guy is the biggest
cloud [ __ ] ever he has a
he has a tattoo of hillary clinton
he says oh you think she's next
well no that's how maybe you could go
above kim well her star's faded it's
just pandering right like i just wanted
to get a hillary clinton uh christmas
gift
it's his hero i'm just chilling in cedar
rapids hillary is not anybody's hero it
is pete davidson's hero wanted to get
hillary clinton a christmas gift so i
got a tattoo of my hero wow why is that
a gift for her
i don't know
yeah he's trying to [ __ ] hillary i think
you guys are right
does he know her why is he talking about
her like he knows her thanks for being
such a badass and one of the strongest
people in the universe although it's
funny because kanye posted this as some
weird cons like
totally deranged conspiracy that
oh yeah that it's uh a conspiracy to
to silence him or something yeah
nobody's silencing you kanye we can all
[ __ ] hear you unfortunately i'm
hearing you loud and clear loud and
clear
can't escape it those boots speak for
themselves bro those boots do all the
talking
so there you go
you know oh
oh so they they have met do you think
they got down
wait is she wearing versace
she's wearing one of those she used to
do this a lot it's like it's not like
it's not a kimono exactly but it's like
uh
this strange sort of like one piece
right like look at that it's like a lady
suit look on his face
they just did something i mean they look
guilty hey what is this you guys sent
god please bring our family back i mean
it's just sad dude
that's just sad [ __ ]
no this these are all of his oh this is
just his feed right now well what it was
he deleted all these but
for the past week or so
he's been calling him skeet by the way
just weird juvenile
not funny
posting
from last time we talked about it yeah
yeah this is this is it's faded
old news bro it keeps going up 14 more
images
okay let's see what connie is it's a
running yeah it's an archive let's work
backwards from the newest
um
so he stopped using cabs yeah but
okay whatever i'm up today
so there you go
i'm right you guys are wrong
60
thank you my people
thank you
just saying
if wendy williams was well and on her
show i bet she'd have a lot to say
just saying
you think i could do wendy williams show
we basically do i mean what's the
difference
in history podcast
we need a live audience that just like
showers away with weird
well that's what the polls are for
to get your positive reinforcement i can
say we don't [ __ ] our pants on air
[Laughter]
give it another uh five to ten years and
yeah we'll get a few more pizzas
we're at two hours should we do the
crazy uh preacher this one's good we can
do it next week georgia governor's
slogan is jesus guns and babies you like
this hela
dude our country is full of absolute
[ __ ]
oh jesus she got the bullet points jesus
guns and babies what are you going to do
about babies what does that mean like oh
she means like pro-life
like you want to [ __ ] babies what does
that mean jesus babies
what does it mean jesus i get you like
jesus guns you like guns babies what are
you doing for babies sure collect things
yeah you gotta shoot those babies
you having lots of kids okay good for
you i mean
i'm the one you've been waiting for
awesome
no you're not awesome candice
jesus can do guns and babies all at the
same time whoa
that's a good old time boy
bring your guns and your babies down
we'll be talking about jesus all right
i'ma [ __ ] your baby oh that's not easy
i don't know what she means
i don't know what she means by babies
that means
jesus will be shooting babies jesus
you're going to be shooting babies oh
they knew i'm the one you've been
waiting for
let's check it out candace spelled the
stupidest way possible taylor candice
candies
taylor
oh she has an ad
yeah
i'm fighting for georgia let me see your
babies
give me the babies
the governor's race in georgia has four
establishment politicians
and then there's candace taylor
[Music]
and i'm one of you
and god made me a fighter
you sold us out to china you hijacked
our relations and then there's dude her
accent is so wild are you scared baby
would you fight her to your opponent
wait was that like a play on being
muslim because like she was hiding her
hair first and she's like and then she
pulls it off she goes i'm one of you
wait where's [ __ ] here
no
hold on
it's just her like i think she's just
doing a rocky thing oh okay
but yeah i'd be very afraid to fight
this woman and god made me a fighter
god made me a very fire she talks
[Music]
what were you doing playing golf or
trading stock that sounds like a sketch
yeah it's like a
has been comedy of sexual assault over
and over
now i'm done with a good old voice
and it's going to get personal
stacy
it's you and me
that's what the people choose why are
you doing this that's not rigged
dude what are you what are your stance
what are you like what do you want to do
i want a candace taylor oh here's your
platform good wow
number one most important thing this is
the most pressing issue in this country
right now is that there's not enough
guns
so we gotta get people more the united
states there's more guns per capita than
any other country in the world by like a
magnitude of like 50. number one rule of
gun safety carry one
okay awesome i don't think that that is
the first rule of gun safety is to carry
saying as governor
as the governor of georgia i will
mandate that every human being carries a
gun on them be so sick
election reform
oh that's you know i i do think that we
need some voting right reform let's see
what she's uh talking about yeah we
can't expect fraud to go away using the
same process we did in 2020 damn it
i will secure our election by removing
absentee ballots dominion machines
and drop boxes they're still talking
about those machines yeah the dominion
machine is actually suing trump for
defamation because he couldn't approve
obviously that
for like a billion dollars it's awesome
let us do their job
quit handcuffing out our immigration
custom enforcement officers
dude i love her platform can be
summarized and just like
we need ah we need to fund us
this is like the most hateful [ __ ] ever
her platform is just i'm a piece of [ __ ]
vote for me
where does jesus enter the picture by
the way
uh he'll be coming up i'm sure education
critical race theory
that's the first thing has no place in
our schools
these programs oppress
our poor white children
yeah they can practice rooted in
oppression
she says we must protect our children
and establish a learning environment
where they can practice patriotism dude
you sound like a fascist why are the
blocks not all aligned this is very
annoying to me
oh no you're right they're not alive
they're just not aligned you know what's
crazy she was planning this run for a
long time because she looks like she
built this website in the 90s
what's her economic policy and curious
that's the least important one
i intend to focus on georgian growth
infrastructure and economic development
one of the largest industries is farming
i plan to roll out opium and take it
from the afghans we were gonna grow
opium yeah
it says nothing it just says she likes
farmers
cool let's watch this video
candice i love canada i thought that it
was fitting to announce
where i was born
for 18 years in public school education
my community here in baxley
and so the past year we have had the
worst of the worst in our country and in
our state
meet candace
all right
what is that
it's a piggy squealing
all right well that's enough for today i
want to eat some pizza we'll be back on
monday wednesday friday we're gonna keep
the schedule going my friends
it's been a fun time it's been a good
time
right there
that's right that's right it's good to
be back it's been a fun week
like i said i was getting well have a
good weekend
enjoy uh second saturday
tomorrow today's first saturday i don't
wanna be too rooted okay but the lesser
saturday
you don't like that i i don't like i i
feel like it's so disrespectful to
saturday well he he in the end was like
well let's just call it friday then yeah
yeah yeah i'm glad he pulled pulled back
from the brink there
love gabe but
that was that was rude let's go walk out
into um zombie world yeah whatever is
going on just enjoy my pizza first
before i realize
that the war with russia has ended badly
all right
have a good weekend everyone have a good
weekend stay safe don't get nuked two
[Music]
wiper back times what you gonna do with
me then you know and the whole damn crew
goose and gaps with all the guests
you'll see the best podcasts in the
world take it from me jc over chair x3
baby we podcast